life primers is a near-record hunt with
more than 40 blade offenses every day in
London members of this gang in North
London admit they've carried and used
knives since the ages of 10 or 11 and
have become embroiled in postcode
rivalries with other gangs if somebody
touches me here dog whole my whole gangs
will come to your home phones getting
killed over if he touched me I'm
touching you all firmly yeah if he
touched my bridges he touched him him
him on coming off steam but all a gang
member with the red head scarf is an
elder looked up to by the others but it
seems this group is given tasks by
people higher up the chain in return for
perceived protection or acceptance into
the game we didn't choose this life wait
I'm not gonna speak about walking to
meet ball I knew I'd get on one case for
hat to game keys if I get in gear I
would go in like a couple of days would
you mean you would have died in a couple
of days can you just elaborate a little
bit the elder shuts him up you brought
down over the north we lost a miniature
war for nothing just for the money to
restore when you say just for the money
if you're stabbing someone is them where
do you get the money from is it you're
saying you're gonna take over their
clients
[Music]
Oh what somebody you don't even know
yourself but your mates told you we're
gonna be doing some intelligent slave
patrols in the borough of lambeth this
is what the Home Secretary hopes his new
measures will tackle
Sajid Javid says he's increasing the
powers of the police by introducing
knife crime prevention orders which can
be imposed on youngsters over the age of
12 if they're suspected of carrying
knives police can put them under curfew
restrict their movements and access to
social media
there'll be tougher measures - against
retailers selling knives to children and
A+ prevention campaign in the spring it
might mean restrictions in terms of
curfews even in terms of some of the
relationships they can have with the
gang members it can have a order on
making them maybe join a a group that
can help an exit from gangs it can be an
education program it's all about
preventing young people from turning
onto a life on crime and actually
understanding the risks of carrying a
knife Sally Knox's 18 year old son rob
was stabbed to death in 2008 she thinks
the proposals don't go far enough I do
not think that they will work I cannot
understand how these will be implemented
and carried out and I do not think it is
a deterrent to the young people to say
they're going to go on a knife awareness
course we're not going to let you go on
social media you can't go out off the
ten o'clock a lot of these stabbings
happen during the day so how is that
going to help
I wonder if you were able to kind of sit
down with a prime minister for a few
minutes and say I want to explain to you
why I am involved in this life what
would you say Auto deport means for
bargaining to deflate these levels me if
they could comment from sort of
opportunity or push TV so they got
nothing to do
to easily to put some money in to do
investment in their communities and
future opportunities is what they say
they need you wouldn't expect them to
welcome tougher police powers but they
don't think it will reverse the trend in
rising youth violence
Jason Ferrell Sky News